vous êtes plutôt pour ou contre le
nucléaire on a fait cette question un
débat politique mais quand dit la
science je vous propose de démonquer les
mensonges des partisans comme des
adversaires le nucléaire polluent des
tours sinistre crachant une fumée sombre
et radioactive voilà ce que les photos
utilisées dans la presse essaye de vous
faire croire en réalité ce n'est que de
la vapeur d'eau elle n'est jamais en
contact avec le réacteur il y a par
contre des tuyaux cachés qui eux
rejettent des bactéries d'eau chaude des
produits anticorrosifs et même quelques
traces d'hydrogène faiblement
radioactifs oui le nucléaire pollue pour
construire les bâtiments extraire
l’uranium des mines et le traité
chimiquement mais est-ce que les autres
énergies font mieux même les plus
propres ont besoin de grandes quantités
de plastique lithium silicium terres
jusqu'à 16 fois plus de matériaux à
production électrique égale c'est simple
le bilan CO2 du nucléaire et tout
simplement le plus faible en France 3,7
g par kilowattheure en prenant tout en
compte du minage au démantèlement 10
moins que le soleil 300 fois moins que
le charbon et les déchets nucléaires
alors là dessus il y a aussi beaucoup
d'idées reçues déjà une grande partie du
combustible et recyclable on peut en
faire du MOX et c'est reparti pour un
cycle après soyons nets hein c'est pas
encore économiquement très intéressant
donc c'est pas encore largement utilisé
seul 4% est vraiment inutilisable on
appelle ça les déchets ultimes et
effectivement ils sont très dangereux on
va donc les vitrifier les concentrer
dans ce verre noir protecteur qu'on
coule dans des fur en inox placé sous
une épaisse dalles de béton en attendant
d'être stockée on vous parle tout le
temps la télé d'un million 700000 m3 de
déchets nucléaire alors vous imaginez
des entrepôts plein de barils jaunes
avec du liquide vert fluorescent mortel
et ça n'est pas le cas à l'intérieur de
ces barils vous retrouvez généralement
des gants des bottes du béton mais c'est
super décevant bah oui tout ce qui a
servi dans le périmètre d'une centrale
est considéré comme déchets nucléaires
même si il y a aucune trace de
radioactivité en réalité seul 0,25% de
ses déchets sont vraiment vraiment
dangereux pour des millénaires si on les
entaçait tous il tiendrait dans ce petit
cube 60 ans d'électricité française
c'est peu évidemment s'en approcher vous
êtes mort il faut les vitrifier avec le
vert noir ça prend un peu plus de place
mais rien à gérable surtout à des
centaines de mètres sous terre en reste
en pagne ou personne ne mettra les pieds
enfin on espère et les fuites de
substances radioactives dont on parle à
la télé la pollution des eaux de la
nappe phréatique oui ça arrive en 2019
une étude rapportait que 6,4 millions de
personnes en France avaient bu une eau
contaminer au tritium le tritium c'est
un nom qui fait peur mais c'est juste de
l'hydrogène à deux neutrons
naturellement produit dans la haute
atmosphère c'est inoffensif à petite
dose ça tombe bien et quantité dans
l'eau sont mille fois inférieures au
seuil de l'OMS en France on a qu'un seul
cas de pollution grave et c'est en 1981
à cause d'une erreur humaine du
plutonium a été déversé dans la Loire ça
a été un scandale on ne parle pourtant
que de 0,3 g comparé au débit de la
Loire c'est dilué à l'extrême et
l'impact sanitaire a été nul pareil pour
les deux millions de mètres cubes de
radioactif de Fukushima rejeté dans la
mer oui ça fait peur mais on parle de
quelques grammes de trium qu'on a dilué
dans l'immensité de l'océan il y a rien
le nuage de Tchernobyl lui a par contre
contaminé aux césium 137 une grande
partie des sols européens les zones en
rouge foncé restent complètement
habitables mais elles ont vu de
nombreuses populations fuyères ce qui a
été bénéfique pour la nature et les
animaux qui ont pu reprendre leurs
droits ils prospérer loin des hommes la
nature est donc plutôt contente peut-on
en dire autant des autres énergies un
barrage nécessite de noyer des vallées
entières pendant des décennies comme en
Chine ou d'immenses forêts primaires ont
été englouties 1,4 millions d'habitants
dû abandonner définitivement leur maison
le solaire oblige parfois à raser des
forêts comme celle des Landes en France
et artificialisé des centaines de
kilomètres de terre pour égaler la
production d'un réacteur nucléaire en un
an il faut plus de 32 millions de
panneaux solaires 55 millions de mètres
carrés à moins d'installer ça dans des
déserts l'empreinte au sol est juste
désastreuse le nucléaire dans 20-30 ans
il y en aura plus pour faire tourner un
réacteur il faut de l'uranium et comme
toute ressource les stocks sont limités
on peut la recycler mais pas un
définiment heureusement de l'uranium il
y en a beaucoup sur terre
675 fois plus que l'or et il en faut
vraiment peu une tonne de charbon
fournit autant d'énergie qu'une petite
pastille de quelques grammes d'uranium
le potentiel est fou mais ce n'est pas
tout de l’uranium vous en avez dans
votre jardin quelques atomes mais ce
qu'il nous faut nous c'est des filons
qu'on peut facilement miner et sur ce
point les experts on la difficulté à
savoir quand on arrêtera d'en trouver
les plus pessimistes avancent la date de
2070 la plupart des experts estiment
qu'il en reste presque 15 millions de
tonnes exploitables soit un tarissement
des ressources en 2300 ça sans compter
la possibilité qu'on puisse inventer une
technologie qui permet de et utiliser
l’uranium stocké à son plein potentiel
ou récupérer les milliards de tomes qui
se trouvent dans l'eau de mer ou le
charbon en vrai on a vraiment le temps
pour comparer le pétrole gaz on peut
arrêter avant 2050 certains avancent que
le réchauffement climatique va tarir les
cours d'eau augmenter leur température
empêchant de refroidir les centrales et
donc obligé à les arrêter ça c'est
complètement faux et ça déjà été
débenqué en fait ce qui menace le plus
le nucléaire c'est un problème de
ressources humaines et oui pourquoi tu
lancerais ta carrière dans le nucléaire
si demain les centrales pouvaient tout
fermer parce qu'un homme politique ont
décidé ainsi que le moindre accident
puisse faire retourner l'opinion
publique on le voit aux États-Unis ils
veulent relancer la construction de
centrale mais galère à trouver des
travailleurs compétents faut dire
qu'être employé dans le nucléaire ça
fait pas rêver repas de famille la
petite nièce te vois comme un criminel
écocide et pour la tente tu es un
contaminat radioactif dont il faut pas
s'approcher triste cliché le nucléaire
c'est exploitation de l'Afrique il y a
quelques années ce reportage avait
choqué on voyait des populations
habitant près de mine d'uranium
abandonné recyclant le métal des
machines pour faire des fourchettes et
donc oui elles contenait des traces de
radioactivité c'est indéniable il y a eu
un gros problème d'éducation de sécurité
après la fermeture de la mine maintenant
c'est loin de décrire la réalité
l'Afrique ne représente que 18% des
stocks d'uranium sur terre la France est
d'ailleurs fait arnaquer par l'Afrique
du Sud en achetant 1,8 milliards une
mine d'uranium vide ça a été un scandale
qui a conduit au démantèlement d'Areva
pour se fournir en uranium il est vrai
que la France travaille beaucoup avec le
Niger mais aussi l'Australie le
Kazakhstan et l'Ouzbékistan quasiment
pas avec la Russie contrairement à ce
qu'affirmé un homme politique il y a
quand même un pays problématique
Kazakhstan alors les mines là-bas il y a
aucun problème quasiment plus de mineur
tout est automatisé robotisé non le
problème c'est que c'est une dictature
avec des présidents français aux petits
soins maintenant on fait la même chose
pour le pétrole le gaz et même des
panneaux solaires 75% sont produits par
la Chine qui extrait 80% du silicium
mondial et 60% du lithium l'Europe
restera dépendante qu'importe l'énergie
et l'uranium est probablement la
ressource qui a le moins de sang sur les
mains mais elle en a quand même le
nucléaire ça tombe toujours en panne
c'est à la une des journaux cet hiver il
y aura des pénuries d'électricité à
cause des pannes de centrale même si
dans l'eau c'est beaucoup de maintenance
temporaire mais alors pourra-t-on
compter sur notre parc en énergie
renouvelable
25% de puissance installées c'est énorme
la transition énergétique a l'air bien
en marche en France ou pas ces chiffres
sont trompeurs il ne faut pas confondre
le potentiel avec ce qui est réellement
produit petit ruisme le soleil ne tape
pas 24 heures sur 24 le vent ne souffle
pas constamment une éolienne ne marche
en moyenne qu'à 25% de ses capacités un
panneau 15%. ce sont des énergies
intermittentes et quand on compare
activité sur un mois on voit bien que
c'est très irrégulier comparé au
nucléaire il y a pas photo c'est une
énergie pilotable constante de jour
comme de nuit la grosse difficulté pour
l'intermittence c'est que l'électricité
c'est très difficile à stocker une fois
produite elle doit tout de suite être
consommée ça toujours pas inventé la
technologie de batterie qui puisse
supporter tout un réseau électrique
c'est le gros problème du renouvelable
que faire lors d'une nuit d'hiver sans
vent ni soleil deux choix soit on
importe l'électricité verte d'un autre
pays voisin ou alors on utilise une
énergie pilotable on ouvre les vannes
des barrages on booste l'activité des
réacteurs où on démarre des centrales à
pétrole gaz au charbon c'est ce qui sont
obligés de faire en Allemagne et c'est
pas joli le nucléaire coûte cher
52 milliards d'euros c'est le prix pour
construire si nouveau réacteurs
européens décident 2037 ils sont plus
performants plus sécurisés produisent
moins de déchets plus facilement
recyclables on galère depuis des années
en en finir qu'un seul moins en France
parce on en a déjà construit deux en
Chine et en Finlande autant de retours
d'expérience pour corriger les nouvelles
versions 52 milliards c'est une grosse
somme oui mais c'est normal quand c'est
nouveau c'est plus cher il faut amortir
les investissements dans la recherche
ceci dit on parle d'une structure qui va
être utilisée pendant plus de 60 ans au
final ça ne coûtera que 1,5 centimes par
kilowattheure 10 fois moins que ce que
vous payez aujourd'hui alors qu'un
panneau solaire c'est pas forcément un
investissement dans le futur après 12
ans il perd en efficacité se périme
technologiquement pour savoir qui sera
le plus avantageux économiquement sur le
long terme la France a mené une immense
en quête tous les acteurs ont été réunis
autour d'une table même les
anti-nucléaires si scénarios pour 2050
ont été envisagées du 100% renouvelable
ou 50% nucléaires oui on peut pas faire
100% nucléaire car on a tout simplement
pas les ingénieurs pour le faire aussi
vite dans tous les scénarios le
nucléaire est toujours le moins cher
même les plus pessimistes et là on parle
des EPR nouvelle génération
les vieilles centrales qu'on a
aujourd'hui sont totalement amortis et
c'est de très loin la moins chère de
toutes les énergies quand vous lisez
dans la presse que le nucléaire est le
plus cher le chiffre est truqué ils font
les calculs en comptant double le
démantèlement ou en imaginant par
exemple que le renouvelable marche 100%
du temps on l'a vu avec l'intermittence
et juste pas vrai après soyons honnêtes
la facture du nucléaire flambe en cas
d'accident au Japon la facture de
Fukushima et de 170 milliards d'euros
Tchernobyl 200 milliards en 30 ans
imaginez le pire et si les nouveaux
réacteurs européens venaient à ne pas
marcher que les petites pannes se
multiplient au point où les opinions
publiques n'en voudraient plus il
faudrait tout arrêter et ça serait
désastreux des dizaines d'années de
retard et des milliards partis en fumée
la France ne s'en relèverait juste pas
les énergies renouvelables ont aussi
leur risque technologique par exemple
qu'on n'arrive jamais à développer une
grande industrie d'hydrogène capable de
stocker l'énergie à grande échelle et à
le coup ça serait le seul moyen de
rendre ces énergiesiables difficile de
prévoir le futur et c'est ça qui est
compliqué le nucléaire est beaucoup trop
dangereux comme avec les requins ou les
loups les journaux et le cinéma ont créé
une peur chez vous celle d'un jour être
un contaminé radioactif et mourir dans
d'atro souffrance la réalité c'est que
tout ça tient du mythe est-ce que vous
saviez que les panneaux solaires ont
fait 11 fois plus de morts que le
nucléaire bah oui les techniciens qui
tombent des toits un barrage
hydrauliques peut se briser et faire des
milliers de morts en Chine une rupture à
noyée 240 000 personnes comme ça d'un
coup en réalité le nucléaire est le
moins dangereux avec 0,03 morts par
milliards de kilowattheure produit à
côté de l'hydraulique c'est un nain mais
attendez qu'on rajoute le gaz la
biomasse le pétrole et le charbon en
fait les accidents nucléaires sont très
rares en France on en a eu qu'un seul de
graves depuis 50 ans sans répercussions
en dehors de la centrale dans le monde
vous connaissez tous fu kushima
Tchernobyl mais il est aussi kichtime en
Russie TRIMA Island aux États-Unis et au
Royaume-Uni soit 5 accidents majeurs
dans le monde en 70 ans la cause des
erreurs humaines et des problèmes de
conception Fukushima le tsunami a coupé
l'électricité le personnel n'était pas
formé à la technologie américaine les
générateurs de secours n'ont pas pris le
relais le réacteur n'était plus
refroidis la vapeur s'est concentré un
niveau extrême dans la cuve jusqu'à ce
qu'elle cède c'était terrifiant pourtant
Fukushima n'a fait qu'un mort à cause
des radiations ces employés seulement se
sont dit touchés par des troupes de
santé et encore c'est pas sûr par contre
il y a eu 2200 morts lors de
l'évacuation forcée par l'accident les
personnes âgées la panique la peur on
reste très loin des chiffres énoncés par
certains politiques français qui
confondent les morts du tsunami et ceux
de la centrale mais attend il y aura des
victimes indirectes dans le futur avec
les cancers non vu les faibles doses
reçues très certainement pas Tchernobyl
a fait seulement 31 morts directs et en
comptant l'explosion il faudra ajouter
43 autres personnes mortes bien plus
tard un mois ou des années après le
milieu scientifique rajoute encore 4000
à 9000 personnes qui ont potentiellement
eu un cancer avec le nuage mais c'est
flou ah faut coucher mais on observe
effectivement une hausse des cancers de
la thyroïde mais c'est pas à cause de la
radioactivité c'est beaucoup trop tôt
c'est juste que quand on cherche on
trouve vu qu'on dépiste tout le monde
des gens qui avaient des cancers avant
l'accident ont été découverts ce qui
fait artificiellement grossir les
chiffres oui les radiations font peur et
ça permet à certains de manipuler les
chiffres si je vous dis que vous avez
reçu 2400 micro-civertz c'est beaucoup
non c'est pourtant ce que tu reçois
annuellement à cause des radiations
naturelles comme celle du soleil ou des
bananes oui le fruit naturellement
radioactif paradoxalement un travailleur
du nucléaire avec toutes les protections
sera en moyenne moins exposée qu'une
hôtesse de l'air ou plus proche des
radiations spatiales il faut relativiser
en dessous de 100000 microcytes il n'y a
pas de risque mesurable pour la santé
c'est à partir d'un million que là aussi
un très dangereux mais peu d'humains ont
expérimenté ça alors la prochaine fois
que vous voyez un reportage à la télé
avec un gugus qui fait sonner à fond la
caisse un appareil en vous disant que
vous allez tous mourir demandez-lui les
doses vous verrez que c'est souvent
ridicule le nucléaire c'est de droite
c'est vrai qu'au dernière élections il y
avait de quand à gauche seul un petit
fragment le Parti communiste était pour
sauf que quand on fait un sondage dans
les parties la fracture n'est pas aussi
nette les anti-nucléaires sont toujours
en minorité même chez les Verts et c'est
loin d'être incohérent l'éolien et
solaire sont la puressence du
libéralisme un grand marché où toutes
les entreprises peuvent investir le
nucléaire est souvent public etatique et
ça le restera par sécurité les
travailleurs des centrales ont pendant
longtemps lutté pour négocier leurs
droits se sont organisés en syndicat ce
qui est plus facile avec un monopole
d'État qu'une multitude d'entreprises
privées une centrale produit autant que
55 millions de mètres carrés de panneaux
solaires qu'il faut installer entretenir
ce qui demande beaucoup de main d'oeuvre
millions d'euros dans le nucléaire c'est
6 emplois créés dans le renouvelable
trois fois plus en 2030 ça représentera
un demi million de postes après soyons
honnêtes tout ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
le paradoxe des vitres brisés si on
cassait toutes les vitres en France ça
ferait beaucoup de travail pour les
fabricants de vitres mais est-ce que ça
serait vraiment une bonne chose pour la
société La création d'emplois est un
miracle peu d'emploi c'est le signe
d'une industrie et efficace qui peut
baisser ses prix et donc en faire
profiter le plus grand nombre alors
pourquoi des gens sont contre le
nucléaire je vous avoue je suis un peu
déçu j'ai pas trouvé de bonnes raisons
scientifiques d'être contre j'aurais
aimé ça aurait rendu la vidéo plus
impartiale mais non c'est plutôt une
histoire de lutte politique sur fond de
vengeance à une époque Greenpeace lutter
héroïquement contre les tests nucléaires
qui détruisaient la barrière de corail
et contaminer les populations locales le
gouvernement français pour les arrêter
on fait exploser leur bateau tuant une
personne la France a été condamnée
5 pistes n'a jamais pardonné cet acte
électoralement le nucléaire est aux un
ce que l'insécurité est aux autres à
moyen facile de faire peur et la peur ça
fait voter pour certains la fin du
nucléaire est un projet de société qui
s'inscrit dans la décroissance
considérée qu'il faut drastiquement
réduire la consommation revenir à la
nature vivre en sobriété et ça bah c'est
pas possible avec une énergie pas cher
et à profusion qui fait marcher les
usines et les gadgets électroniques tant
qu'elle sera là on ne sera pas contraint
de s'adapter de décroître être
anti-nucléaire c'est aussi une volonté
de rétablir l'égalité mondiale entre les
peuples parce que pour faire marcher une
centrale il faut enrichir l’uranium et
ça c'est un quasi monopole des pays du
Nord
90% des capacités de production les
autres n'ont juste pas droit au risque
d'être accusé de vouloir créer des
bombes comme en Iran et c'est vrai
enrichir pour les centrales permet aussi
de le faire pour les bombes tant que
l'Occident gardera la main mise sur
l'enrichissement ils seront toujours au
dessus en termes de puissance économique
et militaire et ça pour certaines
personnes c'est insupportable ça serait
un frein à la paix et à l'égalité
mondiale être pour le nucléaire c'est
assumer ne pas être le gentil de
l'histoire enfin du moins c'est ce
qu'affirmer un article contredit par
Marianne ça n'empêche pas 75% des
Français dit être favorable il se trouve
que l'Union européenne eux pas trop
parce que ça empêche la libre
concurrence entre les pays de l'Union ça
donne aux états des monopoles naturels
un immense pouvoir de défense et
d'autonomie là où on aimerait pouvoir
créer une grande Europe unie très
interdépendante état d'ailleurs qui en
dehors de l'Europe ont tout intérêt à
financer des lobbys anti-nucléaires
quand tu es un exportateur gazier quand
tu es un géant du pétrole ou même un
grand fabricant de panneaux solaires
c'est tout bénef en Allemagne on
soupçonne même la Russie d'avoir
corrompu des élites pour instaurer une
politique énergétique profitable au gaz
sans le nucléaire ça passe par des
lobbies du troll des scandales facile à
relayer sur les réseaux sociaux il se
trouve qu'en face la communication du
au sol il suffit de voir leur vidéo
Youtube c'est tatijene 50 en chef de
projet communication qui t'a pondu ça
pour faire plaisir la COGIP si vous
voulez de vraies infos sur le nucléaire
suivez plutôt triste en gamin sur
Twitter ou le point Genius sur Youtube
ils font un travail en profondeur sourcé
et très intéressant j'ai mis tout leur
lien en description fond ses îles les
yeux fermés j'entends déjà des
commentaires nous dire ok tes arguments
rationnels mais n'oublie pas que tu vis
loin des risques toi détrompez-vous ma
mère habite en face d'une centrale j'ai
tenu de l’uranium enrichi à travers un
flacon et je me suis allongé sur un
baril de plomb plein de combustibles
nucléaires pourquoi faire vous pouvez
que la radioactivité n'est pas de la
magie noire il faut au moins voir le
nucléaire actuel commun répit le temps
de trouver de nouvelles technologies
fusion avec ITER thorium batterie à
l'hydrogène ou solaire spatiale je suis
persuadé que 2300 ne signera pas la fin
de l'humanité si on investit dans la
science
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]